[Musique]
panique en mer Baltique un documentaire
signé Frédéric Campin et Benoît Laborde
cette panique est-elle justifiée les
pays baltes la Finlande la Suède
Vladimir Poutine a-t-il bel et bien ces
pays dans le viseur avec nous pour en
parler aujourd'hui Pascal Alizard
bienvenue vous êtes sénateur hire du
Calvados vice-président de la commission
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
et des forces armées vous êtes également
membre de la commission des Affaires
européenne au Sénat vous êtes
vice-président du groupe d'amitié
France-Russie et membre de la délégation
franceçais 16 à l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OSCE c'est
l'Organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en Europe Michel Fouchet
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
géographe ancien ambassadeur de France
en Lettonie conseiller du ministre des
Affaires étrangères entre 1997 et 2002
et vous êtes l'auteur de ce livre
Ukraine Russie la carte mentale du duel
paru chez galimar givilé kalibaateit
bienvenue à vous vous êtes docteur en
sciences politiques rattaché à
l'Institut des hautes études en défense
nationale vous êtes l'auteur de cet
article paru dans la revue Champ de Mars
le spectre des menaces russes dans les
pays baltes et je précise que vous êtes
d'origine lituanienne bienvenue
également à vous Axel Gilden vous êtes
grand reporter à L'Express journaliste
franco-suédois avec des origines
finlandaises c'est important pour notre
débat du jour vous avez couvert tous les
continents et vous vous intéressez de
très près ce qui se passe en Europe du
Nord ça tombe bien le titre de ce film
est panique en mer Baltique et c'est ce
qu'il cherche à démontrer tout au long
de ce film cette idée de panique Axel
Gilden est-ce que vous la validé cette
idée de panique est-ce que il vous
semble que cette Europe du Nord est
paniquée alors je sais pas si on peut
employer le mot de si on peut employer
le mot de panique mais surtout ce qui
m'a frappé c'est au lendemain au jour de
l'agression russe en Ukraine
instantanément la totalité des pays du
pourtour Baltique tout le tout le pas le
refouler mais tout le l'impensé toute
l'histoire finalement est revenu en
mémoire de des citoyens et et se sont
dit le l'entreprise avait déjà été
commencée un peu plus tôt de réarmement
et cetera mais
euh ils se sont dit les prochains c'est
peut-être nous il faut vraiment faire
quelque choseou givilé kalibataï c'est
aussi ce que vous avez ressenti au-delà
de ce film mais de peut-être de votre
entourage des gens que vous connaissz
sur place il y a eu ce sentiment au
moment de l'agression russe en Ukraine
alors effectivement déjà effectivement
je suis d'accord avec l'idée que c'est
peut-être pas le mot panique mais plutôt
un alerte euh maintenant ce qui est très
important à comprendre je pense dans ces
pays-là en l'occurrence plus dans les
Pays-Bas l'Estonie la Lettonie la
Lituanie on c'est pas la surprise
stratégique le le 24 février 2022
puisque la menace russe c'est une menace
un peu traditionnelle dans dans ces
pays-là alors ça remonte à l'époque
enfin la Seconde Guerre mondiale issu
Seconde Guerre mondiale puis on a quand
même aussi le tout un discours depuis
2008 et ça on voit très bien dans le
documentaire 2008 la guerre
russo-geéorgienne 2007 juste avant aussi
les cyberattaques massives sur l'Estonie
c'est toujours très difficile
d'attribuer les cyberattaques mais le
suspect enfin effectivement c'est la la
Russie on a puis 2014 2014 c'est la
prise de conscience à la fois de la
classe politique mais aussi des
populations et donc il y a cette idée de
d'être un alerte mais un alerte face à
une menace qui est permanente qui est
permanente qui qui est bien connue une
alerte permanente avec quand même des
pics dans les alertes et peut-être la
guerre en Ukraine qui a été le paroxisme
non Michel Foucher ah bah c'est plus
qu'un paroxisme parce que ça c'est quand
même une invasion une agression et donc
moi le mot panique non non parce que
c'est l'émotion c'est-à-dire en Finlande
c'est très clair parce que ça rappelle
la guerre d'hiver dans les pays
baltes quand on était là-bas avec mes
collègues européens comme ambassadeur
notre souci c'était de protéger leur
souveraineté et de limiter les dégâts de
la propagande parce que la propagande
c'était vous êtes les prochains sur la
liste l'idée de faire peur la propagande
de qui venant de qui de de de l'Est du
grand voisin de l'Est donc la propagande
mais pas de panique non plus c'est
plutôt
l'inquiétude que à Berlin et à Paris on
nit jamais voulu entendre ce qu'ils nous
disaient eux hein on avait nous un
discours de dialogue direct pour des tas
de raisons avec Moscou en en en passant
comme disait col notre grand voisin la
Russie quand vous êtes à varcevi vous
n'aimez pas cette phrase là notre grand
voisin la Russie et on a toujours vu ces
pays qu'on a ignoré et pour l'Ukraine on
a toujours traité l'Ukraine à l'ombre de
la Russie h et donc voyez il y a toute
une révolution mentale qui s'est opérée
mais les les dirigeants de ces pays nous
ont dit maintenant ben on vous l'avait
bien dit mais vous vouliez pas nous
écouter l'aveuglement Pascal Alizard
est-ce que le mot panique vous semble
juste et est-ce que cette menace qu'il
semble ressentir et de façon assez
permanente comme vous venez de le dire
est réelle ou
exagérée je crois que clairement la
menace est réelle d'accord le mot
panique me semble inapproprié ah parce
que je pratique régulièrement mes
collègues parlementaires des pays du
Nord et ce sont des gens extrêmement
lucide sur le sujet peut-être parfois un
peu excessif mais on ne peut pas leur
reprocher l'histoire le démontre très
très très clairement et il se trouve que
j'étais à Vienne à l'OSCE quand les
hostilités ont démarré en Ukraine et
chez un certain nombre de collègues il y
a eu un petit moment je dirais de
sidération parce qu'effectivement il y
avait un passage à l'acte c'était
extrêmement concret il y avait une
agression mais mais mais une fois ce
moment passé effectivement la
détermination est très présente et je
crois que on gagne à les écouter
effectivement mais est-ce que ils sont
du bon côté si vous voulez parce que
l'Union européenne est l'OTAN et comme
on y viendra l'avait dit la présidente
vara Vick freberga qui est interviewé
dans son magnifique français quand il y
a eu le sommet de l'OTAN à rigard la
France était contre d'ailleurs que ça se
passe à rigard elle a dit je veux ça
savoir je veux qu'ils comprenneent à
Moscou ou passe la frontière donc ils se
sentent du bon côté hein de de
l'histoire pour la première fois pour la
première fois a gild il faut dire que ce
sont des des pays qui connaissent les
Russes beaucoup mieux que nous nous le
faisons pourous c'est nous Français nous
c'est nous Français nous Français bon
les les ces payslà la Suède par exemple
a fitrailler 18 fois il 18 guerre avec
la Russie avant que la Suède devienne
devienne neutre et et perd surtout la
Finlande qui est devenu un grand Ducher
russe en 1809 donc il y a eu 18 guerres
donc les Suédois connaissent très bien
les Russes les finlandais encore mieux
parce qu'ils ont sont les seuls à le
avoir tenu la dragé haute pendant la
guerre d'hiver pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
les ruses respectent beaucoup les
finlandais et aussi raison pour laquelle
les Suédois pendant longtemps se sont
dit on on peut désarmer toute façon il y
a les finlandais on en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure qui sont les seuls à pas
avoir des armées à être restés
effectivement vous le dites lucide sur
la men mais que savent-ils que nous ne
savons pas est-ce que les ambitions
territoriales de Vladimir Poutine vont
bien au-delà de l'Ukraine est-ce que
c'est ça qu'ils savent ou qu'ils pensent
et que nous ne savons pas Axel Gilden
oui bien évidemment bah très clairement
la l'URSS l'Union soviétique Staline a
annexé 10 % de la Finlande pendant la
guerre au prix de des pertes
considérables d'accord c'est ce que
Vladimir Poutine a en tête voilà donc
donc c'est ce que les Finlandais ont en
tête ils savent à quoi s'en tenir quant
au pays baltes ils ont été occupés
pendantord euh 70 ans je crois j'ai plus
à l'essue de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
non depuis 1939 depuis German soviétique
91ord trois trois occupations
l'occupation soviétique puis
l'occupation nazi puis de retour
l'occupation soviétique là où l'armée
rouge libérer l'Europe pour les les pays
baltes c'est c'est un discours qu'ils ne
peuvent pas entendre qu'ils ne peuvent
pas cautionner c'est il y a les l po du
passé les on mémor donc les baltes ont
été déportés sous Staline et donc
assassiné massacré donc ils connaissent
ils savent ce dont sont capables les
Russes et c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle pour revenir à l'exemple de la
Suède après la Georgie la Suède a arrêté
cette folie qui consistait à désarmer
complètement donc le point bas du
désarmement suédois c'est en 2009 juste
après la geéorgie et juste après
l'Ukraine ou effectivement depuis la
guerre en la première invasion de
première l'annexion de la Crimée 2014
depuis ce moment-là comme Michel Foucher
vient de le dire la Suède la Finlande
les autres pays alertent les capitales
que parisien et berlinoise pour dire
attention attention il ne se passe rien
mais le chef d'état-major suédois en
2015 je crois ou 2016 dit on a sa
population au Suédois et c'est vraiment
le moment du du Grand Réveil suédois qui
est quand même le pays le plus peuplé de
la région nous pouvons tenir une semaine
face au rus et là à l'époque le budget
de la défense était de 1 % là on va vers
2 % Pascal alizar un fait majeur très
récent qui est peut-être le signe sinon
d'une panique au moins d'une grande
fébrilité le pays la Finlande vient
d'acheter un système anti missile
israélien l'un des plus développés au
monde capable de détruire des cibles
volants à une altitude minimale de 15 km
un contrat historique signé le 12
novembre dernier avec Israël comment
interpréter cela est-ce que ça veut dire
que la Finlande est en train de se
réarmer est-ce que c'est un message
juste un message envoyé à Poutine ou
est-ce que ça pourrait vraiment servir
écoutez c'est les deux c'est
effectivement un message extrêmement
clair envoyé à Vladimir Poutine je crois
qu'effectivement le le le grand voisin
ne connaît que le rapport de force et et
les équilibres et les principes de
dissuasion donc là il y a il y a un acte
fort c'est c'est c'est pas des mots
c'est un acte fort posé par le pays et
puis concrètement une fois que les
missiles vont être là euh ils peuvent
servir en cas de besoin donc
effectivement et et on est dans une
situation aujourd'hui certes de
réarmement un peu tous aimut mais mais
on est encore loin au niveau de l'OTAN
de l'objectif des 2 % pour chaque pays
on est de l'ordre d'un % et demi bon la
France est en train de se rapprocher des
2 % d'autres pays font aussi de gros
efforts l'Allemagne qui est concernée
par le sujet fait elle-même de gros
efforts la Suède et d'autres il y a
effectivement de la de la conscription
qui se remet en en place avec des forces
territoriales et et et des réserves ce
sont des pays qui ont des réserves
opérationnelles militaires
quantitativement supérieures à au Ain
c'est voilà on parle de 250 à 300000
hommes c'est quand même colossal on n
pas ça en France aujourd'hui donc c'est
une réalité et je rappelle que la
Russie 140 millions d'habitants c'est le
PIB de l'Espagne plus 10 % he donc il
faut pondérer les choses mais les
dépenses militaires c'est 30 % du PIB
c'est colossal etcite de l'OTAN Michel
Foucher on voit dans le film que des
soldats de l'OTAN sont présents se sont
positionnés dans les trois pays Bales et
en Pologne présence seulement dissuasive
on rassure les Estoniens a dit le
colonel Éric Moget dans le film présence
seulement dissuis l'otant là il
attention à toute la propagande qui
circule et à la fois à Moscou et à Paris
dans certains partis pas représenter ici
heureusement l'OTAN c'est une alliance
défensive donc l'argument servi au au
pays du tiermonde ou à la Chine que en
fait la Russie ne fait que se défendre
d'une agression de l'OTAN tout ça ça ne
tient pas moi quand j'étais ambassadeur
on a organisé avec Madame aliomarie la
participation de la France à la police
du ciel avec une escadrie qui était
basée sur l'aéroport lituanien de
chaolay ça ne plaisait pas du tout à
Moscou mais on l'a fait donc la France
l'Allemagne enfin tous les pays
européens participent avec les
Américains et on est plus nombreux hein
à cette défense du flan oriental de
l'OTAN depuis 2 ans mais l'engagement
est bien plus ancien que la la guerre en
Ukraine en fait ça s'est accéléré moi
j'étais en poche jusqu'en 2006 on a
lancé la police du ciel à ce moment-là
pour la Lettonie arrêtons-nous un
instant sur cette alliance Atlantique
qui attire tant les pays menacés et vous
allez peut-être me répondre givilet
kalibateit c'est une présence qui irrite
aussi Vladimir Poutine donc c'est aussi
un peu à double Tranchon depuis 49 le
nombre de pays membres est passé de 12 à
31 il y a eu neuf vagues d'élargissement
les pays baltes en font parti depuis
2004 la Finlande est le dernier pays à
l'avoir rejoindre c'était le 4 avril
2023 la Suède arrive c'est en cours
d'adhésion et actuellement trois pays
souhaitent adhérer la bosnieherzégovine
la Géorgie et l'Ukraine c'est un un gage
de sécurité pour ces pays l'UTAN ah oui
tout à fait la la défense collective
c'est l'un des principaux éléments de de
leur politique de défense à côté de la
défense territoriale qui commence à se
redévelopper en dehors de l'Estonie où
c'était ça ça ça s'est jamais arrêté
parce qu'ils ont cette tradition de
coopération coopération avec la Finlande
et donc les cultures stratégiques un peu
similaires voilà mais dans en Lettonie
Lituanie la défense territoriale c'était
un peu mis de côté aujourd'hui ça se
développe mais défense territoriale
résilience de la nation et de l'état
plus défense collectif c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'extrêmement important et
je rejoins aussi cette idée qu'il faut
aussi souvent souligner c'est que
l'alliance militaire donc l'OTAN c'est
une alliance militaire défensive et les
Baltes ils étaient souvent demandeurs de
plus de garantiese de plus de preuves et
l'OT temp était généralement plus plus
réticente à mettre un œuvre concrète
beaucoup beaucoupf répondre justement
pour pas froisser et donc si on regarde
très progressivement le temps ne fait
que répondre aux actions très concrètes
de ce que fait la Russie de Poutine
c'est chaque fois un réponse par rapport
à ce que fait la Russie et avec un petit
décalage généralement parce que d'abord
il a l'action russe puis la réponse de
l'OTAN à à la demande c'est ça je trouve
intéressant et complexe c'est que l'OTAN
c'est à la fois un gage de sécurité de
réassurance de ces pays mais c'est aussi
précisément ce qui irrite Vladimir
Poutine a oui mais je pense que c'est
c'est aussi le moment de de tirer un
coup de chapeau aussi au Finlandais
parce que les finlandais comme vous
l'avez évoqué n'ont jamais désarmé non
pas supprimé leur service militaire ont
conservé leur artillerie qui est
considérable il y a 1400 pièces
d'artillerie en Finlande c'est plus que
la France et la Grande-Bretagne réunie
et ils n'ont jamais acheté cette
histoire de la cette cette ce narratif
de la fin de l'histoire ils sont restés
droit dans leur botes tandis que les
autres pays regardaient et s' imaginit
que la menace avait disparu donc l'OTAN
s'appuie d'abord sur la Finlande ENF je
ne s'appuie pas sur rien l'OTAN n'arrive
pas en sauveur dans des pays en friche
d'une part il y avait la Finlande il y a
toujours la Finlande avec son armée de
défense territoriale et de défense
civile qui est capable de passer en une
semaine de 60000 soldats à 280000
d'accord parce que tout le monde sait et
il y a une armée de réserve qui est
entraîné par rotation il entraînent
30000 soldats de réserves tous les ans
alors si vous êtes réserv service tous
les 5 ans environ vous faites une
période de de d'entraînement et chacun
sait en Finlande mais vous pouvez
discuter avec n'importe quel chauffeur
de taxi vous le dira qu'il est
réserviste et que il sait très bien si
en cas de guerre où il doit se rendre
quelle garnison il doit faire quel est
son grade et cetera quelle est sa
fonction et ça concerne les femmes ça
concerne les hommes donc il y a une
armée en état de fonctionner quand même
280000 c'est pas rien et en plus de ça
vous avez alors des armées qui sont
beaucoup plus petites en nombre de
combattants mais qui ont quand même en
apport
technologique enfin militaire hard power
avion bateau tank notamment l'aviation
avec la Suède la la Norvège et la le
Danemark et la Finlande qui est en train
d'acheter 64
F35 voilà il a y a y a il y a de quoi
s'appuyer et bien sûr l'OT temp est
important dans ce dispositif parce que
c'est très marqué dans le film et je
crois qu'il y a quelque chose qu'il faut
rappeler non seulement c'est une
alliance défensive mais c'est une
décision souveraine des États concernés
d'adhérer le discours de l'extension de
l'OTAN pendant des années
euh les gouvernements américains
successifs étai réticents à
l'élargissement de l'OTAN et c'est en
particulier un conseiller d'origine
lituanienne de Carter Ron asmus qui a
réussi à faire
évoluer non seulement le département
d'État mais la Maison Blanche donc c'est
un acte de souveraineté et critiquer ce
qu'on appelle les issement c'est
reconnaître que Moscou a naturellement
droit à une zone d'influence impériale
et comme chacun sait ça a été dit par
metvedev l'Empire n'a pas de frontière
là on est en train de fixer pour la
première fois une frontière qui est en
même temps partiellement une ligne de
franc outre la menace militaire que fait
peser la Russie sur ces pays de la mer
Baltique il y a la pression migratoire
qu'exerce Moscou d'ailleurs la Finlande
là encore ne s'y trompe pas le pays
vient de fermer son dernier point de
passage frontalier avec la Russie elsink
accuse Moscou de laisser des migrants
sans papier franchir sa frontière on en
reparlera tout à l'heure et il y a une
autre forme de pression celle qui passe
par les communautés russophones c'est un
sujet qui est largement évoqué dans le
film et que j'ai trouvé particulièrement
intéressant parce que on l'évoque assez
rarement en tout cas ici en France
écoutez cet
extrait cela a certainement été la
volonté et le souhait de la Russie de
garder des populations russophones dans
toute l'Europe pas seulement dans les
pays baltes
l'Allemagne par exemple compte 2
millions de russophones la Russie est
parvenue à garder les personnes âgées
dans sa sphère d'influence médiatique
mais pas les plus
jeunes Pascal Alizard j'ai trouvé que
c'était un passage passionnant dans ce
film ça voudrait dire que peut-être
Vladimir Poutine utilise les communautés
russophones dans les pays pour
potentiellement trouver prétexte à une
attaque c'est comme ça qu'il faut
comprendre STR je crois que c'est comme
ça qu'il faut effectivement le lire euh
c'est sont des communautés importantes
dans les pays baltes mais en Allemagne
enfin c'est parfaitement dit dans le
dans le documentaire et et c'est le
prétexte idéal le moment donné pour le
dirigeant russe du moment parce qu'on
parle de Monsieur Poutine mais enfin
demain c'est plus monsieur Poutine il y
a quand même des constantes hein dans la
politique russe depuis depuis toujours
et c'est effectivement le prétexte
parfait pour intervenir euh on le on le
craint sur cette espace du Nord on le
vit sur d'autres espaces euh quand on
regarde ce qui s'est passé en Georgie en
2008 ou quand on regarde ce qui se passe
actuellement en Ukraine c'est aussi
c'est aussi un sujet il considère que ce
sont des bouts de Russie des petits
bouts de Russie qu'il faut aller
récupérer c'est effectivement la logique
de l'Empire c'est avoir des pays tampon
le terme est pas très joli mais c'est
quand même un petit peu ça appelons ça
des marches si on veut être un peu plus
élégant mais mais mais mais il
considèrent que que c'est leur immédiat
proche
hou je souviens d'éch avec un assadeur
de Russie à
parisz on par on parlait du Partenariat
oriental qui est quand même une
politique assez softe de l'Union
européenne ça n'a rien à voir avec une
intégration dans le temp ça irritait
déjà les Russes au plus haut point et et
l'ambassadeur nous disait mais mais
quand vous proposez ça à ces pays c'est
un peu comme si vous demandier à un
enfant s'il préfère son papa ou sa maman
je cite c'est vous dire l'état d'esprit
HM cet ambassadeur et la considération
c'estàdire en fait la non considération
qu'il porte à ces pays et et je crois
que quand on s'intéresse au sujet il
faut ESS effectivement essayer de
rentrer dans la mentalité russe dans la
lecture qu'ils ont bien de de ces pays
qui finalement ils considèent qu'il leur
appartiennent parce que les chiffres
sont impressionnants he pour comprendre
l'ampleur de cette question
démographique les min les minorités
russes représentent 26,5 % ce ne sont
pas des minorités russes ouais attention
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire ce sont des
populations qui sont venus dans les pays
baltes parce que c'était euh la Russie
d'Europe on y vivait plutôt mieux
qu'ailleurs dans tous les domaines il y
avait des activités industrielles
agricoles ce sont des gens de langue
maternelle russe une partie d'entre eux
les plus âgés les babouchka et souvent
les hommes refuse de passer l'examen
linguistique c'est surtout vrai
d'ailleurs en Lettonie parce que la mais
alors justement pardon on peut juste VO
les chiffres Michel FCH juste pour que
nos téléspectateurs comprennent 26,5 %
de la population en Estonie oui 26 % en
Lettonie 5,8 % en lituan son pas des
minorités russes des minorités
russophones alors ils sont d'abord tout
le monde était russophone jusqu'à
maintenant et tous les gens DEP plus 30
ans sont russophones et deuxièmement les
tris/4 d'entre eux ont passé l'examen
linguistique et ont maintenant la
citoyenneté de ces pays mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu un problème avec ce qu'on a
appelé d'un terme un peu malheureux mais
accepté par le Conseil de l'Europe de
non citoyen c'estàd il y a des gens qui
se sentaient un peu apatride mais ils
étaient surtout orphelins de l'Union
soviétique alors c'est vrai que la
politique dite des compatriotes est un
outil d'influence c'est d'ailleurs dans
la doctrine de sécurité de yelsin de
défendre et quand Poutine a déclaré la
fin de l'Union soviétique est la plus
grande catastrophe géopolitique du 20e
siècle on a complètement mal compris ce
qu'il a dit il parlait pas de rapport de
force stratégique il parlait précisément
de la dispersion des russophones et
voyez il y a toujours cette vision
ethnolinguistique de la nation hein qui
est d'ailleurs assez fréquente en Europe
orientale et on confond en russe il y a
deux termes pour dire être russe il y a
le Russe racist qui est qui est le russe
de la Fédération de Russie et puis
Rossier c'est russe
ethnolinguistiquement russe et là il y a
une confusion qui est entretenueata en
effet c'est pas forcément le la ils sont
c'est pas parce que nous sommes une
minorité russophone nous sommes
forcément
prooutine le cas lituanien il est assez
intéressant comparé aux deux autres pays
baltes dans le sens où un un Loni en
Estonie c'est effectivement aux
alentours de 25 % des minorités
russophones qu'on qu'on ressense en
Lituanie c'est autour de 5 % et la
minorité la plus importante parce
queeffectivement on a des statistiques
ethniques dans dans ces pays-là c'est
une minorité dite polonaise et
maintenant quand on regarde les
minorités polonaises et russes enfin et
polonaise on voit que parfois leur
positionnement peut être assez similaire
sur un certain nombre de sujets de la
politique internationale et ce n'est pas
forcément parce qu'ils sont de ces
minoritésl les questions elles peuvent
être un peu plus complexes c'est aussi
parce queil y a des fractures sociales
dans les pays qu'il faut reconnaître que
d'ailleurs euh le discours de de
kremelin aime bien instrumentalisé
justement pour décrédibiliser ces
pays-là auprès des de leurs partenaires
occidentaux euh les fractures et existe
le niveau de vie de de ces populations
là souvent est un peu moins important
et Moscou appuie là-dessus pour diviser
voilà voilà Moscou appuie là-dessus pour
diviser et de la même manière Moscou
dirige la propagande le discours de la
propagande maintenant un peu moins parce
que ce discours il est beaucoup plus
disons enfin limité de fait des
sanctions qui sont entrepris envers les
envers les les médias du cremelin mais
Moscou peut s'appuyer peut diriger le
discours envers ses minorités pour dire
écoutez vous voyez
euh ça peut marcher les il vont le
discours va ça va conser pour dire
l'époque soviétique c'était mieux pour
les personnes simples vous voyez donc on
va alimenter un peu la nostalgie de
l'époque soviétique et ça peut marcher
parce que si on regarde les sondages en
Lituanie de 2016 il faut le reconnaître
pour les questions de posées est-ce que
vous considérez vous apprécier Vladimir
Poutine les minorités ces minorités
ethniques elles étaient assez
importantes tente en nombre pas loin de
70 % 80 % à dire que oui nous apprécions
plutôt la politique de Poutine en 2016
ça veut dire que c'est après la Crimée
aujourd'hui ces statistiques j'ai pas
des données de Statistiques et les
dirigeants politiques c'est très bien
montré dans le documentaire sont très
réticents et enfin c'est pas forcément
rétiscant mais ils sont très attentifs à
dire attention c'est pas parce que il
s'agit des minorités qu'elles sont
forcément pro russes j'imagine
qu'effectivement il y a des données qui
per oui la question qui se pose c'est de
savoir s'il y a une 5è colonne dans ces
pays-là voilà donc pour ce qui est de
l'Estonie on a bien vu en 2007 lorsque
l'Estonie s'est montré dans le
documentaire a déboulonné cette statue
soviétique qu'effectivement il y avait
une masse mobilisable je crois qu'avec
le temps les choses évoluent c'est dit
également par une des présidentes
interviewé dans le
documentaire que il y a un clivage en
fait générationnel Pascal Elisa mais
pour prendre un parallèle avec la
situation en Ukraine où là aussi il y a
des familles russes ou russophones c'est
une culture assez similaire après la
Crimée après les événements du donbas
vous aviez encore 30 % de sympathie pour
Poutine en Ukraine et il a fallu les
événements qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
pour que tout ça s'effondre et tombe à
moins de 2 % c'est des chiffres qui
m'ont été donnés quand je suis allé à
Kiev il y a quelques mois mais malgré
les éléments les événements de Crimée et
du donbas il y avait encore 30 % des
Ukrainiens parce que la famille parce
que la culture et cetera qui qui avait
de la sympathie pour voilà al alors là
c'est effondré parce que les événements
sont graves mais mais il n'empêche quand
même que c'est prignant la la Moscou se
sert aussi des migrants je l'ai un petit
peu évoqué tout à l'heure pour faire
pression la Finlande n'est pas la seule
à s'en plaindre en août dernier la
Pologne a tiré la sonnette d'alarme et
beauou un afflux record de migrants
orchestrés par la Russie et la
Biélorussie vers l'Union européenne qui
peut m'expliquer cette stratégie Michel
Fuchet on comprend bien qu'il y a une
angoisse dans nos sociétés occidentales
sur la question migratoire et donc il
déstabilise les c'est un pouvoir c'est
une tentative un élément de la guerre
hybride j'allais dire c'est la guerre
hybride il y a une palette et ça fait
partie de la palette on est d'accord
c'est un pouvoir de nuisance la
coopération a pas marché mais et c'est
vrai que la le pouvoir de nuisance est
très fort comme le pouvoir de propagande
il y a une vraie continuité si vous
voulez et donc bah les les les Polonais
ont pris les mesures qui qui
s'imposaient et la Finlande la Finlande
qui ferme tout ces mais ça porte en
Finlande c'est quelques centaines de
personnes c'est d'ailleurs pas la
première fois parce que ça avit déjà été
tenté dans à partir de Mourmand avec des
Africains d'ailleurs on se demandait ce
qu'il faisait dans la région de Mourmand
hein pour aller en Norvège donc si vous
voulez tout ça c'est c'est d'une
stupidité extraordinaire c'est cousu de
fil blanc donc on comprend tout de suite
ce qui se passe hein et tout le flux de
charter c'est complètement arrêté mais
enfin ça nous perturbe quand même non
alors en 2019 je crois le ENF le nombre
de migrants illégaux recensé par les
gardes frontières lituaniennes c'était
49 donc c'est un bus en 2021 on trouve
en juillet je crois en juin 2000 3000
personnes qui cherchent à traverser la
frontière donc on peut imaginer que les
services les gares frontières les les
services de l'État ne sont pas armé
enfin dans le sens VO outillés ne sont
pas outillés pour euh pour gérer ces
flux les populations ne sont pas euh
enfin ne sont pas habitués à ces flux là
non plus et donc ça cherche aussi à
déstabiliser les les populations à créé
la euh oui il a créé le le chaos au sein
de la société à et ça prépare en quelque
sorte ce qui se passe ensuite tout
simplement enfin le on a c'est une sorte
de déstabilisation culturelle tentative
de déstabilis tentative tentative de
déstabilisation c'est pas forcément
déstabilisation culturel c'est euh on on
va Saer la confiance dans les
institutions on va on va dire vous voyez
votre état n'est pas capable de gérer
enfin alors que si finalement ils ont
réussi à gérer pourquoi chantage parce
qu' à la lisard vous dites chantage il y
a une forme de chantage parce que on
essaie de démontrer que on peut
effectivement vous nuir euh vous envoyez
une population euh qui qui n'est pas la
vôtre que vous ne souhaitez pas que vous
ne pourrez pas contrôler et démontrer
que finalement votre état n'est pas
compétent pour gérer ça et et en fait
bah ce chantage n'a pas payé puisque euh
les les États concernés on ont tout de
suite réagi ont tout de suite pris des
mesures l'Union européenne a pris des
mesures mais regardez de l'autre côté un
petit peu plus au sud et un petit peu
plus à l'est Erdogan fait à peu près la
même chose hein euh max Gilden cette
pourrait tout à fait préfigurer quelque
chose qui nous concernerait
effectivement en Méditerranée il
pourrait absolument faire la même chose
mais effectivement c'est ce qu'on tout
le monde a dit autour de plateau c'est
c'est un élément de la guerre hybride il
y a plusieurs choses il y a ça il y a la
guerre de de l'information il y a la
politique d'influence on n' pas parlé
aussi de de la dépendance énergétique
hein que Vladimir Poutine a a provoqué
alors elle est très présente dans dans
ce film notamment avec le le gaz russe
et nthstam 1 et nthstam 2 qui a capoté à
cause de la guerre en Ukraine mais cette
dépendance fait partie de cette Guer
hybride que que Vladimir Poutine a
provoqué chez nous en Europe et
particulièrement des pays comme
l'Allemagne c'est plus compliqué parce
que là le gaz c'est un gisement un
contrat un tuyau et un consommateur
et on a tous toutes les enfin on avait à
quelques milliers de kilomètres un gaz
plutôt bon marché hein bien moins cher
que le gaz naturel licfié américain ou
du Qatar avec un un fournisseur Gazprom
déjà au moment de la guerre froide qui
était fiable euh en gros il y a eu deux
ou trois exceptions avec l'Ukraine euh
et qui permettait à l'industrie
française
allemande de à bon marché de produire
des machines util pour le marché chinois
donc ça c'était le modèle économique
allemand donc je là je je dirais que il
y a certainement eu un calcul du
kremelin notamment avec Nordstream 2 euh
que Madame Merkel a accepté je dirais en
toute naïveté en fait parce que elle est
toujours été très préoccupée par la
prospérité allemande et l'encrage
démocratique de son pays surtout dans ex
Allemagne de
l'Est là on est il y a une complicité si
vous voulez qui est main il y a eu un
calcul au départ il y a eu une intention
il a il y a eu il y a oui mais enfin on
a laissé faire mais clairement dit parce
qu'on a été naïf peut-être clairement la
la carte des hydrocarbures euh a été
progressivement arsenalisé si vous
voulez c'est-à-dire on se rend compte
que dans la globalisation mais c'est la
même chose en Chine euh aujourd'hui les
flux économiques peuvent être
arsenalisés militarisés c'estàd devenir
des outils géopollytique mais là aussi
ça n'a pas marché parce qu' enfin
d'abord on continue à acheter du gaz
russe hein et il n'est pas sous sanction
parce qu'il faut respecter les contrats
à long terme pour la crédibilité de nos
entreprises on peut en penser ce qu'on
veut et on a Ré réussi à à s'en passer
en fait du pétrole et cetera mais il y a
beaucoup de contournement si vous voulez
mais le calcul le calcul poutinien n'a
pas marché rien n'a marché on va dire
sur Nordstream 2 bon effectivement
l'Allemagne était très très très en
pointe en fait ça a quand même beaucoup
discuter je dire il faut reprendre les
débats en
France ça ça discutait quand même
énormément sur le sujet bon à contrario
quand on voit l'arsenal russe positionné
au Bélarus et dans enclave de
caliningrade les premiers exposés c'est
quand même les Allemands c'est la
Pologne c'est les pays baltes et c'est
le nord de l'Angleterre la France est
quand même alors après il y a d'autres
moyens mais la France c'est quand même
j'ai j'ai j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
participer il y a quelques temps Parlier
des vols la réassurance de l'OTAN j'ai
j'ai fait j'ai accompagné j'ai pas fait
j'ai accompagné une mission à wax bon on
est monté par la terre on est redescendu
par la Baltique voilà je peux vous dire
que alors je pas rentrer dans les
détails mais mais c'est extrêmement
impressionnant alors l'arsenal russe est
extrêmement impressionnant mais le
contrearsenal de l' temp et lui-même
tout autant impressionnant et et et et
au-delà de nos sujets ça interroge quand
même à long terme un peu sur la folie
des hommes quand vous voyez tout ça
parce que là vous les voyez vraiment
mais en fait dans cette stratégie hbride
dont on parle rien n'a marché finalement
je ni l'arme énergétique ni l'arme des
migrants ni l'arme euh ni l'arme de de
l'influence des réseaux sociaux et en
réalité on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec
une mère pu de la Baltique qui était à
l'époque de la guerre froide un lac
soviétique quasiment parce qu'on partait
de la l'Allemagne de l'Est la Pologne
caliningrade tous les pays-balles
jusqu'à Saint-Pétersbourg et aujourd'hui
à l'exception de Saint-Pétersbourg et de
caliningrade tout le reste c'est
quasiment l'OTAN donc on on est
aujourd'hui on est passé dansun lac
soviétique à une mer otanienne quoi
c'est une déite stratégque c'est aussi
maritime c'est quelque chose qu'on a du
mal à on le voit que la partie allemande
mais le rideau de fer était maritime il
allait jusqu'à Mourmand et le deuxième
élément c'est il y a la Baltique mais
l'histoire ne se limite pas à l'échelle
de la bâtile ce qui est important dans
toute l'histoire de la sécurité
européenne c'est l'axe l'isme Baltique
mer Noire c'est là que ça joue depuis
toujours et et et l'Ukraine est sur cet
axe Baltique mer Noire j'ai vil
galibatille peut-être pour conclure cet
échange entre nous sur ce plateau est-ce
que d'après vous Vladimir Poutine a
d'autres cartes à jouer en plus de
toutes celles qu'on a évoqué on a parlé
de la carte énergétique la carte
migratoire la carte militaire évidemment
même on a parlé de évoqué d'un mot la
cyberattaque est-ce que Vladimir Poutine
a autre chose d'autres leviers déjà le
le spectre effectivement de des outils
est assez large évoqué dans cette
émission on peut parler aussi de
l'information on n pas énormément parlé
mais la propagande ça ça joue énormément
la manipulation de l'information la
déstabilisation des des sociétés en
interne mais on le voit pas uniquement
dans les pays baltes pas uniquement dans
l'espace Baltique mais on le voit aussi
dans dans les grandes démocraties
Occident
Poutine qui essaé de d'intervenir dans
les les processus électoraux donc c'est
quelque chose très à surveiller de très
près et de pas être naïf parce que là on
parlait effectivement du norstam et un
peu peut-être de naïveté pas naïveté
attention dès 2005 les pays baltes mais
ils alertaient ils dénonçaient ils
utilisaient parfois même le langage
assez assez virulant en disant
effectivement c'est un Pact molot
ribrope qui est en train de se refaire
attention l'Allemagne aujourd'hui c'est
un partenaire c'est un allié centrale
dans cette région mais sur ce ce ce
domaine là dans dans la les questions de
sécurité énergétique c'était extrêmement
dénoncé donc on peut pas dire que
personne le savait les les Balt le
disaent parfois on les traitait un peu
de d'hystérique ou trop alarmiste en
tout cas paranoï dans le film d'ailleurs
voilà paranoïque ou en tout cas les pay
d'un seul sujet sauf que finalement
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec une
puissance qui cherche à à élargir sa
voilà sa zone d'influence qui challenge
l'Impérial ENF qui qui est impérial et
qui est qui n'est pas uniquement dans
l'espace Baltique on la retrouve en
Afrique aussi non juste un point parce
que c'est quasiment le seul point de
désaccord que j'ai avec le documentaire
ne soyons pas naïf et ne pensons pas que
la Russie est isolée l'Occident l'a
isolé avec toutes les mesures que nous
avons pris mais la Russie n'est pas
isolée ne commettons pas cette erreur ex
gen à mot de conclusion il faut écouter
les pays du pourtour de la mer Baltique
car ce sont eux qui connaissent le mieux
les Russes un dernier aussi Michel fouch
peut-être c'est notre sécurité qui se
joue sur flan oriental merci pour ces
mots de conclusion court merci à vous
merci d'avoir participé à cet échange
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi comme
chaque semaine on se retrouve très très
vite sur public sa à
[Musique]
bientôt y